es el mayor mercado de electrónica del
mundo cuenta con miles de tiendas que
venden al por mayor todo tipo de
componentes como Microchips que Son
imprescindibles para fabricar teléfonos
televisores y otros aparatos sus
propietarios se han despertado y con la
noticia y que tenían que cerrar y que
tendrán que someterse a test diarios
antes de reabrir el viernes en Génesis
la ciudad que mejor metaforiza la
transformación de china en las últimas
cuatro décadas era una aldea de
pescadores y hoy es la ciudad más
moderna de China cuenta con 17 millones
de habitantes y hace años ya que superó
el pib de Hong Kong es también el
epicentro de la Revolución tecnológica y
sede de gigantes como Huawei ese
probable que el cierre del mercado
afecte a la economía local porque de la
alta tecnología llega el 20% de ella y
además es también bastante probable que
acabe afectando a las cadenas de
suministro globales el gobierno local ha
dictado el cierre al mercado tras haber
detectado El domingo apenas
tiene la reputación de luchar con mucha
contundencia contra el coronavirus en
marzo sofocó un brote en apenas una
semana dictando un encierro instantáneo
mientras En aquellos días sanjay
retrasaba la toma de medidas y acababa
provocando una desastrosa cuarentena de
casi tres meses